[Music]
missing at Sea this Monday night a
vessel taking tourists to the Titanic
shipwreck vanishes there could have been
an accident the search off Canada's
coast and how long people can survive
inside this submersible
gripped by grief the support for
manitobans morning loved ones lost in
that terrible bus crash
on the front lines of the fight against
Russia
Global News is with Ukrainian soldiers
inside the tank shooting down drones and
missiles
and trying to pouch things up it is very
important the U.S and China work on
their complicated relationship
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcha good
evening and thanks for joining us a
major search and rescue operation is
underway tonight a vessel that takes
tourists and scientists to see the wreck
of the Titanic is missing off the coast
of Newfoundland there are five people on
board with enough oxygen for just a few
days the submersible was scheduled to
depart from St John's on June 12th for
an eight-day round trip to the wreckage
site roughly 600 kilometers away it was
reported missing after it lost
communication sometime on Sunday
what we're really focused on at the
moment is really locating the vassal
which could either be in the surface or
subsurface and so we're bringing in
technical expertise to understand uh
both the Dynamics of underwater uh
search and underwater rescue operations
the vessel is believed to be the Titan
operated by Ocean Gate Expeditions
capable of diving 4 000 meters
underwater resources from the U.S and
Canada have been deployed in the air and
on the water to look for the missing sub
Eric Sorensen reports on the desperate
search now underway
it is a 10-ton high-tech submersible
that can transport five people to the
bottom of the ocean and it's gone
missing a Canadian search vessel and a
Canadian Forces Aurora aircraft have
been deployed along with a usc-130 to
the waters off Newfoundland and Labrador
where the Titanic is located Ocean Gate
operates the sub and says contact was
lost Sunday ocean Gates says in a
statement we are exploring and
mobilizing all options to bring the crew
back safely and receiving assistance
from several government agencies and
deep sea companies in our efforts to
re-establish contact with the
submersible the once in a lifetime
opportunity in its promotional video
Ocean Gate offers what it calls citizen
scientists the opportunity to dive down
to explore the Titanic platform ready to
dive the cost is several tens of
thousands of dollars per person with
clientele like director James Cameron
the adventure acknowledges risks but
emphasizes safety I think the the
greatest likelihood is the loss of
communications but certainly anything is
possible Jill heinerth has been in touch
with the crew on the surface vessel the
polar Prince she says there are many
Fail-Safe measures on the sub they can
drop the ballast that holds some
underwater and simply float back to the
surface I mean this is a 8 to 12 hour
mission just to go down and back to the
Titanic there is life support capacity
on board these subs for about 96 hours
so they have a lot of time the
submersible is almost seven meters long
about 22 feet the capacity is designed
for five people for up to 96 hours or
four days it can descend to a depth of 4
000 meters the Titanic's depth is 3 800
meters below the surface on the ocean
floor at that depth something serious
could have happened the Titanic lies in
a trench there is debris all around
there could have been an accident it
could have been come entangled in the
wreckage of Titanic it could indeed have
had a catastrophic failure the answer we
don't know just yet the Titanic was one
of the world's worst Maritime disasters
more than 1500 lives were lost when it
struck an iceberg and sank exploring it
has been a Fascination for people like
BC's Ron toygo about whom Global News
once did a story it's always been one of
those things that you just mesmerized by
for and why who knows tonight the lives
of five more people are the subject of a
frantic search very near where the
search for the Titanic happened 111
years ago Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
later on global national we'll speak to
CBS News correspondent David Pogue who
traveled on the Titanic tour submersible
last year
in Manitoba autopsies have begun to
identify the 15 people who were killed
in last week's bus crash police now say
they have spoken to some survivors but
the investigation is going to be a long
process
all the witnesses were in the bus and a
lot of them are in trauma right now that
we can't talk to so we have to rely on
Forensic investigations mechanical
analysis of the vehicle and and things
like that and that's why it's taking so
long
10 people remain in hospital five are
now in critical care Rosanna Hempel
reports from Dolphin Manitoba tonight
where most of the victims are from
connecting with her community and
talking about her grief is helping
Sandra Kalida cope with Thursday's crash
you have to
um because mental health is so important
one of her close friends passed in the
tragedy although she knew nearly
everyone on board on Monday Sandra and
her husband Glenn helped tour therapy
dogs around local assisted living
facilities to help others with their
grief they have been very receptive
to the dogs we had 36 come out from St
George's
um to you know pet the dogs talk to talk
to them many of those affected are
members of Dauphin Senior Center where
Sandra says grief support groups are
also open to the public a few blocks
away Billy Graham's rapid response team
is offering emotional and spiritual
support chaplain coordinator Wanda
berchert says on their first day Monday
they've already met with a few residents
who knew the victims we recognize that
the local resources of the community are
not always sufficient to help everybody
that's been impacted and obviously like
dolphin is a small smaller community
and so we just come in to support
anybody in the community city council is
holding a private meeting Monday night
discussing donations and the legitimacy
of some online fundraisers and whether
the city will organize a public Memorial
we just don't know enough to know what's
needed so we know don't want to you know
be in people's faces necessarily we
don't want to set something up that's
too soon for Sandra and Glenn they're
getting by helping others and trying to
go on themselves these are grandparents
and and great-grandparents and moms and
dads you know that they we have lost
Rosanna Hempel Global News in Dolphin
Manitoba
federal health officials are warning
Canadians about poor air quality from
Wildfire smoke smothering communities
across the country in recent weeks
Wildfire smoke can impact air quality
over vast distances affecting the
respiratory health of people who live
hundreds or even thousands of kilometers
away
more than one hundred thousand Canadians
have had to leave their home so far this
year air quality monitors have been sent
to Nova Scotia Quebec and Yukon BC will
get them in the weeks ahead as well
people are being advised to limit time
Outdoors when smoke levels are high and
consider masking up to help filter out
harmful particles
it hasn't only been the worst spring
Wildfire season nationally the same goes
for BC there are about 60 active
wildfires in that Province right now the
Donny Creek wildfire in BC's Northeast
has grown to more than 534 thousand
hectares it remains out of control but
an evacuation order for surrounding
areas has been lifted that Wildfire is
expected to burn into the fall
in the House of Commons today the
Trudeau government was asked to respond
to a document recently released by the
RCMP that suggested prime minister
Justin Trudeau was under investigation
for matters relating to the snc lavalin
affair the matter involved allegations
that in 2018 Trudeau improperly
pressured then Justice Minister Jody
Wilson raybold for favorable legal
treatment of the montreal-based
engineering firm snc lavalin but late
this afternoon an RCMP spokesperson told
Global News the document released
contained incorrect information and that
there is no ongoing investigation into
the snc Saga the RCMP said it concluded
there was insufficient evidence to
proceed
Alexi navalny defiant and defending
against extremism charges coming up the
new trial for the Russian president's
most outspoken critic plus
I'm Crystal gabans and Global News has
been given access to the air defense
team which is working to keep people in
the city safe we'll have their story
coming up
the Russian president's number one rival
opposition leader Alexi navalny is
facing a new trial that could keep him
locked up in prison for decades
navalny is facing new charges of
extremism Vladimir Putin's biggest
critic is already serving a nine-year
sentence for parole violations fraud and
contempt of court charges navalny and
his supporters say are politically
motivated to keep Putin in power navalny
faces multiple charges in this new case
that include creating an extremist
Network and financing extremist activity
if convicted navalny could spend an
additional 30 years behind bars
ever since Putin waged the war in
Ukraine citizens have been terrorized at
nightfall under the cover of Darkness
Russian forces fire a barrage of
missiles and drone attacks and as
ukrainians take cover air defense units
only have a few minutes to intercept and
Destroy threats from above our Crystal
gomancing was granted special access to
an air defense unit near the Ukrainian
capital
in a beast they've nicknamed the Dragon
for its size and power this squad of
young soldiers harnesses a gepard to
slay their enemies
drones are not difficult for her at all
Roman were only using his first name
commands the team of three which
includes Alex and alexand they were all
trained on the anti-aircraft system in
Germany the gephard with its twin 35
millimeter cannons was developed in the
60s Germany decommissioned the units
more than a decade ago then last year
the gephards were donated and pressed
into service in defense of Ukraine
the automatic cannons can engage targets
within 6 000 meters protecting people
and critical infrastructure in the
capital region with a high rate of
success
the first Downing we had was a cruise
missile says Alex she flew past us we
captured her and shot her down it was
Winter and of course there was Joy yes
fact during the month of May Ukrainian
officials say the capital was targeted
on 21 days by Russian aerial attacks air
defense systems have been able to
intercept those incoming drones and
missiles giving residents a bit of Hope
when people hear a drone which sounds
similar to a moped in the sky they pause
listening optimistically for a
successful air defense takedown
it's a feeling a short-term feeling of
inspiration that we are doing the right
job Roman was an engineer before the
full invasion the 28 year old has
learned every inch of his gephard he
walks Global News through where the
links of ammunition are fed down below
the Gunner highlights the onboard radar
and shows us his seat in the turret it's
really hard to give a true understanding
of it but it is an incredibly small
little space it's expected this Summer
that the first rounds of German produced
ammunition will be sent to Ukraine the
gephard can fire more than 1 000 rounds
per minute earlier this year Germany's
defense minister announced a deal with a
local manufacturer to start producing
the rounds in country again to ensure
Ukraine would have a steady supply of
ammunition Switzerland is debating the
sale of its warm materials to third
parties so Ukraine could benefit
Roman speaks a little English and makes
a clear ask of Canada and all Allied
Nations
protecting their country means
protecting their families Alex used to
be a bartender the 31 year old was known
for his pina coladas now he serves his
country just like his mom and dad who
are on the front lines
I worry and they worry we try to call
each other every day if possible
ukrainians are battling on all fronts to
protect their people and secure their
borders countries have donated several
different types of anti-aircraft weapons
to be used around the country including
34 gephards from Germany Roman Alex and
Alexander say they can rely on their
dragon and are ready to release it when
needed
Crystal commencing global news keep
region Ukraine
[Music]
tense ties ahead the U.S and China try
to stabilize their
nearly 170 people have died in two of
India's most populous states from a
sweltering Heat Wave temperatures are
soaring as high as 43 degrees Celsius
most of the victims were over the age of
60 and had pre-existing health
conditions hospitals are overwhelmed
with patients severe water shortages
often accompany India's intense heat
waves leaving tens of millions of people
without running water
there was a surprise face-to-face
meeting in Beijing today between Chinese
president Xi Jinping and U.S Secretary
of State Anthony blinken blinken is in
China as part of efforts to pull the U.S
China relationship back from the brink
as Jackson prosco reports both countries
are hoping to turn away from a path that
could lead them into direct conflict
their unexpected meeting capped off a
diplomatic mission to stabilize the U.S
China relationship
U.S Secretary of State Anthony blinken
and China's Xi Jinping spoke frankly as
president XI said the two countries need
to find the right way to get along
have an obligation to responsibly manage
our relationship Lincoln's visit was
supposed to have happened in February
but was postponed by the alleged Chinese
spy balloon found in U.S airspace since
then things have only gotten worse with
simmering tensions over Taiwan spying
and concerns over Chinese military
assistance to Russia for its war in
Ukraine we were in an increasingly
unstable place in our relationship I
think this is the start of a process to
put a little more stability into it she
insisted there were agreements on
specific issues exactly what is unclear
the U.S reaffirmed it does not support
an independent Taiwan but is concerned
by what it calls China's provocative
actions in the Taiwan Strait and South
China Sea I think the progress that was
made at this was simply clearing the way
for the resumption of normal diplomatic
contacts yet Beijing rejected a key U.S
request for direct military to military
Communications to avoid a miscalculation
or conflict Beijing insists it's being
stifled by American activities the U.S
says it simply wants competition we're
each engaging in Behavior that's very
familiar in the Cold War and that's
happening so cold war or not it's got a
lot of Echoes and it's dangerous still
the highest level meeting in five years
left both sides believing they're
perhaps on a better course and if all
goes well she and U.S President Joe
Biden may meet face to face in November
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
[Music]
speak with a journalist who joined a
mission with Ocean Gate Expeditions
about the risks of riding in a
submersible
[Music]
CBS correspondent David Pogue joined an
expedition to the Titanic wreckage last
year riding in Ocean Gate specially
designed submersible vehicle and David
joins me now so David first of all what
is your reaction to the news of the
missing tour submersible
I mean I I know the people who run the
company I know some of the people on
this week's trip
I I'm I'm kind of freaking out and and
also wondering how it's possible I mean
there is a lot of safety a lot of
checklists a lot of redundant systems
built into this thing it must have been
something really freakish what is your
understanding of how this could happen
so the first thing I I worried about the
night before I went on it was that we'd
run out of air or that we'd get a leak
and implode so or that we'd be stuck on
the bottom so there's four days worth of
air in there they're already one day in
so three left
um they have seven different methods for
returning to the surface like dropping
off weights or using their propellers
and so on so it seems like if they are
anywhere they could only be one of two
places either they came back to the
surface and they've lost power which is
why they can't radio anybody and they're
just bobbing somewhere or the nightmare
scenarios that they got trapped down
there they got hooked on something or
snagged and they can't return to the
surface and in that case there's no good
ending to the story because there's no
other craft that can go down there and
get them it's a one of a kind right I
want to ask you because I understand
when you went on the journey last year
there were some weather related delays
and and a failure of the communication
system can you tell us about that and
how confident you felt as you were
preparing to go
what I don't think most people don't
realize is this thing takes paying
passengers out to the Shipwreck for five
days at a time so that gives them five
tries to get in the sub and visit the
Titanic this is the third year they've
done it they go out five times each
summer and most weeks they get down only
once out of the five all the other times
either there's bad weather or a
mechanical failure and on that note so
given the technical setbacks on past
Dives were small ones does this time
feel different
it does because this time they have lost
communication with the ship on the
surface there are supposed to be short
text messages that can be sent and
there's supposed to be safety pings once
every 15 minutes and neither of those
has happened in over 24 hours so that
indicates that the power has gone out
and it's
it's really bad it's dangerously cold
and I mean this is day two
um so that's another worry in addition
to they're not equipped with anything
but snacks and one water bottle when you
were at the deepest depths of the voyage
that you were on how safe did you feel
it turns out that I was worried about
the wrong things I I really lost sleep
the night before I was kind of a mess
but I was worried about getting back to
the surface and running out of air and
again those are two things that I didn't
need to worry about when I asked
Stockton Rush what he worries about this
is what he told me getting snagged the
sea is full of these mile long fishing
nets that have been cut free they call
them ghost Nets and if the sub gets
snagged in one of those
it's over
all right that is CBS correspondent
David Pogue David thank you very much
thank you
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm nitu garcha tonight's your
Canada is the final resting place of
those who died on the Lost Patrol in
1910. three members of the royal
Northwest Mounted Police and their guide
left Fort McPherson in the Northwest
Territories but they never made it to
their destination of Dawson City Yukon
thanks for watching have a great night
foreign
[Music]
thank you